hello grammarians today i want to
introduce the idea of the verb tense and
the way i want to do that is to express
the following if you can master
grammatical tenses you will become a
time wizard a literal actual time wizard
because tense is nothing more than the
ability of verbs to situate themselves
in time
specifically in three different times so
in the past the present or the future it
can happen
when we're talking about a verb a verb
can happen now
a verb can happen later
and a verb can have happened in the past
then
that's basically it
and if you master tenses you will be
able to tell stories that span all of
time
uh and i think that that ability is
kind of astonishing that language can
express
that sort of idea to just give a very
simple example i'll just take the word
talk and put it in these three
basic tenses now it does get more
complicated than this sure but we'll
cover that later so if i say
if i take the verb to talk
and i put it in the present
i would just say
i
talk
the most basic iteration i talk in the
future
i
will talk
and in the past
i
talked
this is the simple form of every english
tense past present future
if you can command all of these you will
be a time wizard
that's you
you can learn anything
david out